this list is the next billion dollar
startups list and it is a look at
fast-growing venture-backed companies
that we think are the most likely to hit
that billion dollar valuation we do this
list in conjunction with our partners at
trubridge who can help us to gather all
the data they reach out to a few hundred
vc firms we reach out to dozens of
companies personally that we think are
interesting and the first stage of the
list is a quantitative analysis so we
look at
numbers like revenue revenue growth
valuation valuation growth etc
and come up with a list of candidates
that we think are
potentially extremely interesting and
then we do reporting from there this
year the average 2020 revenue was just
12 million that compares to 30 million
last year
uh also this year we had six companies
that rang up under five million in
revenue the previous year we had zero so
what we're seeing now is that companies
on this list are hitting the list
earlier
their earlier stage companies hitting it
earlier in their life cycle but are
attracting significant amounts of
venture funding because of their fast
growth some standout companies this year
we we had notarize which does online
notarization
we had squire technologies which does
software for barber shops we had viz.ai
which is using ai to help people who
have strokes get treated fast enough we
had
two
crypto blockchain companies on the list
for the first time uh with both abra
which is a crypto bank and alchemy which
is a blockchain
developer we also had a number of
healthcare companies including neo and
incredible health we also had a number
of security companies a number of
software companies uh obviously the list
is extremely tech and healthcare related
right now we tracked revenue for the
previous year to the year's list so a
few years ago we had a number of retail
companies consumer products companies on
the list that's not the case right now
right now it's very focused on
business to business applications
healthcare applications
uh other things along those lines so
it'll be interesting in the future to
see if you know we'll retail bounce back
and we'll see more of those kinds of
companies on the list again
as that was not the case this year
you